so in my review for kick-ass 2 I
mentioned that I didn't really
understand where the critics were hating
so much on it with paranoia I completely
understand
[Music]
paranoia is directed by Robert Luketic
he's a man behind Legally Blonde
monster-in-law 21 the ugly truth and
killers and now he gets to direct the
movie starring Harrison Ford Gary Oldman
and Richard Dreyfuss I guess all you got
to do to direct three legends of the
acting field is make some shit movies
this movie also stars Liam Hemsworth and
Amber Heard and it's billed as a
thriller basically this movies about a
guy Liam Hemsworth he wants to be really
rich and to do that he tries to sell
various products to Gary Oldman who is a
pretty high up guy in the field of
phones I guess and phone related
products Gary Oldman eventually then
recruits him to spy on Harrison Ford's
character who is a competitor in the
same business and that starts this web
of intrigue and deceit
between these three individuals so how
is paranoia well last time I checked
this movie has a 2 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes meaning is one of the worst
reviewed films of the year I cannot
believe that Harrison Ford Gary Oldman
Richard Dreyfuss and even Liam Hemsworth
read this script and said yeah let's do
it who's the director yeah the guy who
made monster-in-law the ugly truth and
killers yeah let's get into direct the
movie that reunites Harrison Ford and
gary oldman again the last time they
were on-screen together it was Air Force
One and it was pretty awesome
this movie is fucking awful I mean I
really hated paranoia
I couldn't stand this movie it's just
scene after scene of characters talking
and winking and looking and smiling and
maybe we'll have some kind of intense
dialogue err or scene at some point but
guess what it's gonna be film too shit
and it's gonna be lit too shit this
movie looks like a made-for-tv movie
this mm-hmm
this looks like the kind of movie that
was made for TV in like 1999 every shot
is lit so poorly and certain shots are
framed so off-center where they start to
cut off the people's eyebrows even when
they're on screen you're like you're
cutting off parts of their face dude
with the camera the film looks terrible
I mean during this one chase scene where
Liam Hemsworth it's like running like a
girl I don't even know what was going on
but he
like this I'm not even exaggerating the
celli runs what is he doing who told him
to run like that during the chase scene
the director seems to think that he
should like insert like flashed images
where the words like bow like let's have
him be there and then there and then
there and then there in the same shot
all in one time it's like what does that
even mean I really hate this one a lot
okay so the directions horrible you got
that I said that the script ludicrous
horrible boring uninteresting bland
dialogue and an ending that doesn't make
any sense to me
like certain things happen I don't
understand like why were certain
characters being rewarded and certain
characters being punished there's one
care coming yeah okay yeah yeah okay I
get a heat this song back what the other
guy do he didn't do anything why is he
in trouble
why is liam hemsworth smiling wow this
movie it's not good it's a thriller with
no thrills this is a boring movie I
can't even really say like what genre
this movie is it's not a comedy because
it's not funny it's not an action movie
because it has no action in it it's not
a thriller because it's not thrilling
Harrison Ford and Gary Oldman and really
everyone just seems like they're trying
to give something to it and there's
nothing there it's like how'd they get
there in this movie was the script
originally something else was a
different director attached at some
point who said yeah let's do this cuz
this movie sucks man never watch this
movie ever don't see it in theaters
don't rent it don't even stream it
illegally online do not let anyone know
that you watch this movie don't add a
viewcount to any type of legal thing
like don't let anyone know you saw don't
see paranoid there's nothing good about
this movie at all the only thing I can
possibly say is good about the movie is
that Harrison Ford and Gary Oldman were
trying that's it they tried good job
guys why is it even called paranoia no
one in the movies paranoid wow I'm gonna
get paranoia an F it's definitely one of
the worst movies I've seen all year I
hate it don't see it I feel better
thanks as always for watching guys I
appreciate it very much
and if you did like this you can click
right here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]